hey I'm going to talk to a mentor what  question should I ask what do I believe  to be true that isn't whoa great  question right if I talk to somebody I  can tell they cast these views of what  is and what isn't about business about  marriage about health and then they  operate off of that framework of  assumptions which might be patently  false and then they wonder why what  they're doing is not working it's like  because the entire Foundation upon which  you built this thing is just wrong no  the easiest way to do that is to get  people ahead of you tell you by the way  I don't think that belief is true but  you have to get in a place that somebody  can actually communicate that to you and  be open to